joining us right here at the top of hour
number two is one of our favorites it's
been a while since we've spoken to him
he's been on some frogger walkabout and
the uh in the down under he's back from
australia back on good morning football
he will be back
on his podcast ten questions with kyle
brandt and the ringer kyle brant back
here on the show how are you kyle
thrilled to be here thrilled to talk to
you i've missed you and i usually like
to start with something glib or
something from hollywood but rich i have
to say i hated
sitting at home watching what you went
through with covet how are you feeling
i'm good man i appreciate it i
appreciate it i didn't like it either
god
yeah i know uh everybody should stay
safe and again my message is still get
vaccinated that's what kept me out of
the hospital and being sick and um you
know all good thank you for saying that
i'm glad you hear you say it and i know
that you were um in canton ohio as well
yes and i know you discovered something
there you told me off the air and i know
you haven't said it on the air but i'm
gonna debut
ohio you told me that they are already
making the bus for bears quarterback
justin fields is that true i need to
check my notes yes they are actually i
knew it yeah and i bet it's beautiful
what do you think bro what do you think
i mean it's
it's 103 year history of the chicago
bears and um
the idea that they found this guy and
this is the end of 103 years is it's not
just exciting it is downright
intoxicating and um i'm already i think
you can qualify as i'm the war path i
think i'm on the war path that he should
get on the field and
i'm beside myself already that they're
going to start this season
on national television at so far stadium
down the street from you and it's going
to be andy dalton against the rams and
i'm terrified and i think it's going to
happen and i'm angry about it already
well
the the
concept of throwing him in the deep end
of the pool against aaron donald and
jalen ramsey where you know obviously
half the field will disappear just
because of ramsay
and donald will be in his face and
whatnot
uh behind an offensive line that is
already you know banged up significantly
i i get it but
he did play for the ohio state
university and he did throw every damn
uh every damn throw on the route tree on
clemson you know and let's go you know
what what do you think that he's just
going to turn out to be
less than mike tomzack which is the bar
for ohio state quarterbacks of the
chicago bears you know like honest like
it's it's
like let's let's go let's see what you
got yeah first of all there was a time
when it was time zach versus harbaugh
for the bears in michigan versus ohio
that was when i was in childhood rich i
don't believe as it pertains to this
rams thing you don't we don't dodge
players
we don't say well he's he's a guy they
got a great d tackle so let's wait let's
protect them no no no this guy played
the biggest football there is and if
we're going to do that well you know
aaron donald's out there let's let's not
do that within week three they're going
against the brown so we should be
protecting mint miles garrett to enjoy
being cut no it's the nfl level every
team is good players i don't believe in
that i do believe in this i think we are
seeing rich something a sea change here
and i think that you me probably most
people listening were raised on this
idea of you draft the quarterback and
you make weight you let him marinate you
you wait until he's ready and he put i
think it's time to re-examine that i
think this position is different i think
the college players are different i
think the high school quarterbacks are
different the seven on seven the
coaching i think they're better faster
and this idea it always sounds great
we're gonna be practical and
conservative and we're gonna can you
imagine the the football crime it would
have been to the la chargers last year
if the misfortune had not happened tyrod
taylor their starter which was a freak
accident that allowed justin herbert to
come on the field and have the greatest
rookie quarterback season ever
the only reason that happened is because
of the wild anomaly thing that happened
at our retail if not herbert's just
sitting there we don't even see him and
the list goes on and this is right now
richardson all these people are saying
well brady waited and rogers waited and
breeze waited
russell wilson didn't wait there's fifty
other guys who didn't wait joe flacco
coming out with the ravens and wait
roethlisberger barely waited to sean
waited one half with the texans
sometimes guys just have it and put in
justin fields right now behind andy
dalton god love them
there was a time someone said you know
russell wilson this rookie you got to
put him behind matt flynn just just give
him some time right nonsense
there it's a case-by-case thing here
well i mean the the issue is that your
coach uh was front and center watching
mahomes wait all the way through to week
17 and that's i think
you know something that informs his
thought process here but the difference
is alex smith had already had years in
the system and a locker room that had
fully
known him for a while
um where dalton has just kind of dropped
in there and
uh i i i i just think it it it would be
wise to do it and then you know you get
his feet wet in the word you know
significant way who knows what can
happen and then he's against two ohio
teams coming up next the bengals and the
browns and then you
i i i just think it's the right move to
do like what the hell are you waiting
for i know and if if i may the mad
maggie thing is is everywhere because
he's on the reed staff the draft
i've thought about this for a while and
this is now looked at as this
this michelangelo's david of how you
start a quarterback's career he waited
and he waited he learned and that's why
he's mahomes i i have to call such bs on
that i'm i'm really sure that if patrick
holmes had started from day one he would
have been brilliant i i with due respect
to coach reed and alex smith i'm sure
they did have a very positive effect on
them and the homes have talked about
that i don't care my homes would have
been better than alex smith that year we
don't know how these things would have
shaken up that's a very good cheese team
they might have won the super bowl that
year if they started mahomes from day
one so i'm kind of done with that whole
thing
just design i remember lamar sitting
around for months waiting for a back
nine joe flacco to finally hand the job
over and there was a sensation you can
mess this up and i don't want the bears
to do it
this is why brockman and i have worked
together so long i knew that back nine
joe flacco is now on our list of
potential fantasy team names you're
writing it down right right chris yeah i
wrote down that one and less than tom
zach is pretty good less than tom zach
is not bad
you know like you could you can have
like tom zak's face on a less than zero
meme right like you can do something
like that or just joe flacco playing
golf would be pretty good too oh my sure
we could do a week-long show on field
versus dalton like you you i am visceral
on this one like any wedding right now
talking to you and it's unlike kyle
brandt here on the rich island show it's
unlike any of the other situations
because you've got um the first two
teams that drafted a quarterback they're
definitely starting
uh they're guys in jacksonville and the
jets and trey lance and jimmy garoppolo
are totally different ball of wax
because garoppolo took him to his super
bowl two years ago lance
last played a game of any significance a
a year plus ago so you can get his feet
wet and also have a package or something
like that for him and then belichick's
like anybody who asks him what are you
going to do with cam and and
and mac i'll be just like hey
2001
with brady and bledsoe are holding that
beer you gotta be kidding me this one's
totally different a totally different
ball of wax it's wild and and mad maggie
is it's it's so hard to get a grip on
him this time of year because
there were two years ago as we don't
play anybody in the pre-season to
biscuits not touching the field and max
not touching the field and now the guys
are all over the preseason and rich and
i talked about this a lot last year now
he gets wild like he ripped her biscuit
off the field in two seconds after
swearing that he was gonna stick with
and then he puts holes in and then rip
falls out again and so he's trying not
to flip-flop on this thing
here's what it is can i share with you
the justin fields andy dalton
uh indigenous the chicago metaphor that
i've come up with because i think i can
get inside matt maggie's head okay
okay so you're a chicago bears fan and
justin fields is this unbelievably
beautiful delicious looking slice of
pizza and it gets put down in front of
you and damn you are hungry and you've
waited so long you've waited hours days
maybe your whole life for this pizza and
you just want to dive into it but you're
smart
and you've been down this road with
other slices and you know that if you
bite into it immediately is going to
burn the ever living hell out of the
roof of your mouth you know that's
coming so you say hold on let me wait
because in the meantime you have also
ordered a caesar salad you didn't even
really want it but you thought you
should have it was the minimum order for
delivery you still have a few bites of
the caesar that's andy dalton he is the
caesar salad you have a few bites it's
not bad it's okay
you've got many like it it'll sort of
get the job done so you have a few bites
finally you bite into like an overly
stale crouton area enough with the
caesar but in the meantime the pizza has
cooled off a little bit and that's been
justin field sitting there you say well
i bet still hot but it's not problem hot
so now i can enjoy it it's cooled off i
did the caesar thing the salad walked so
the pizza could run
that is what matt maggie looks at justin
fields like i'm not biting into that
thing because i gotta enjoy this pizza
without the five layers of mouth skin
being burned off so give me some caesar
for a while and then we'll get there
kyle brandt's breakdown of the chicago
bears quarterback brought to you by uber
eats everybody
five stars in a tip please
well done kyle brown here on the rich
eisen show what the hell does frogger
look like with human beings
what do we got that's coming up on
peacock next month is that where it
starts next month on peacock imagine the
old coin up frogger machine in the 80s
arcade maybe the one that george
cassandra played with jerry yes um
imagine this rich yes you you go through
your career and you work and you try and
try to get breaks and you work your
contacts you just hope that someday
someone will come to you and offer you a
really cool job the soundbite that i got
about this job about doing this live
action frogger show was yeah we want you
to do play-by-play and see if you can do
this do you think you could call it
like it's a football game but also make
like a bunch of 80s movies references oh
my god and i'm like
you came to the right place
and that's what i did it was amazing you
were built for this you were built for
this kyle built my gosh so excited so i
love the video games i it's sports it's
football but then you know i i can step
in and i can quote
uh let me think of an actor i like i can
quote uh all mister mom gung ho
multiplicity
1989 tim burton batman any of those
would work yes i love it he's coming up
shortly but did did you did you
did you tell them i i i just you know
when when they asked you can you call
frogger like a football game with 80s
uh movies references did you send them
to your legal staff of whitman price and
haddad
i have it at 10 after the 12 after the
hour well that's the first mention of my
uh law firm from the running man of
whitman price and hijabis mentioned i'm
so proud of us rich i did not mention
whitman
i'm not even joking there was in the in
the taping of frogger i did make the
reference to mad dog ben richard
i hope it makes hair
i am uh you say i'm maria conchita along
so into this gig you know like that's
[Music]
it i can't wait to see it man i know
it's really cool
you know you take this sort of loosely
wipe out formula but just make it all
video games like huge 80s uh injection
it's myself it's damon wayans jr and
it's just it's just
more uh maria conchita lonzo you could
ever possibly want i actually pushed for
them to be in yellow spandex jumpsuits
i understand we're going to have the uh
the stalkers come after them it's going
to be dynamo
mr jim brown will reprise his role as
fireball and it's just going to be great
and he was jesse the body venture well
he wasn't the mind yet the bodies
as captain freedom with his home video
workout
and then uh your pod coming back on the
ringer next month as well correct yeah
season three
questions set up on spotify and the
ringer it's again a game show
conversation um it's awesome i love
doing it and uh
i love being on this show because i
remember richard and i talked once i
think we were at the draft and we were
put into some dressing room area or
something like that and i was talking
about the the hollywood injection you
have on to this show i'm just like if i
ever get invited on the show is that
because daniel day lewis pulled out i
don't understand you guys have the most
amazing guests and so i i see twitter
and it's like oh yeah i'm on it michael
keaton is honest right after me i'm just
opening for keaton you are indeed you're
opening for michael oh my gosh oh by the
way so i got about a minute left you got
a prediction for his steelers what do
you think there i have a shrug emoji
with them i don't know what they're
going to be like this year at all you
know the other teams are so sexy in the
division aren't they i know and they the
timeline teams never lose and yet listen
rich it's it's almost the season of
picking your your division winners and
your wild card winners and um
i i think they're going to be looked on
as
ben stayed one year too late i really do
i think baker lamar even burrow i i i
think he's gonna stay one year too late
we'll find out because he's on the uh
the what the the br07 system that's
right you know
he's shown he's shown up looking a lot
better than he has shown up to a lot of
other training camps walking boot
included walking boot and speaking of
seven uh richard it reminds me of my
favorite ever michael keaton line tim
martin mole they're in the house and mr
mom keaton says want a beer it's seven
o'clock in the morning
scotch
i love it i've said it to my friends a
million times and practiced it take care
of yourself kyle let's do this on the
regular as much as you're uh willing i
always love you guys thank you
that's kyle brandt everybody
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here